what's good Josh your boy ddg man catch
me on the bootleg Kev podcast
show special guest
my guy ddg
what's up man new album
well by the time this is uh Out the
album will be out yep yes make sure you
go listen give it a listen man go buy it
on iTunes big features you got Polo G
Italy Choppa a baby face Ray obviously
gun is on the album we've heard that
song for a while I'm forgetting somebody
else
um Kevin Gates who you were on tour with
yeah
what was that like it was fun man he's a
great guy I feel like he's a little
misunderstood yeah yeah he cool dude
he's in great shape too man yeah I need
to work out every day I saw him with
that wheel today on oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
was it was like he's also known as like
one of the best performers
do you feel like you learned anything
from him
watching him for me it was it was just
really like
I would say inspiring just to see all
them people probably know yeah I wasn't
even promoting the tour to be honest
like I wasn't like posting about it or
nothing like that right like I was just
on the shows but them [ __ ] was
packed packed out one might say why
would you even agree to do the tour if
you didn't plan on promoting it it
wasn't a plan on promoting it it's just
I just wasn't you know I just wasn't
actively promoting because I'm like this
[ __ ] is already sold out it's an
already sold out too yeah what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna promote I'm standing outside
that [ __ ] you know I'm standing outside
and listen to my [ __ ] from from the
street it didn't make no sense so I was
just like the whole tour was sold out
yeah for the most part that's big man he
was doing like random ass [ __ ] like we
was at the bottom of Mississippi and
[ __ ] random ass cities where was like uh
any any like weird situations you found
yourself in being in any of those random
cities
um
nah not really it was just I don't know
people just different everywhere yeah
but it was you know it was cool
was this your first like super big big
tour yeah that was my first time like
going on tour with somebody yeah like I
usually just do my own tour right was it
uh obviously bigger venues than you used
to yeah hell yeah for sure he was doing
amphitheaters yeah he was doing some big
things someone was Arenas though Arena
I'm stop saying it's crazy man nah that
[ __ ] was lit can you try to convert you
to Muslim nah no no no no I feel like I
feel like a lot of people hang out with
Kevin Gates and then I interview him
after and they're a Muslim man
that ain't happening you did he didn't
try he didn't have a little combo about
it nah yeah [ __ ] hella spiritual though
he you know he'd be saying [ __ ] like you
know what's the most hella spiritual
thing he said to you that you kept with
you
um it was a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] a
lot of [ __ ] yeah cool though man you do
any mushrooms on tour with him
nah I tried it though you tried some
shrooms yeah for the first time and I I
look I tried it before right yeah
but like
I ain't feel nothing I'm like you know
you didn't eat enough some [ __ ]
right yeah I know you big on mushrooms
of course yeah yeah I got some gummies
for you for real yeah yeah but no I I
tried this [ __ ] or whatever because I
was hearing someone's positive [ __ ]
about it yeah last time we talked you
hadn't tried them yet yeah like I was
hearing oh it opens your mind I think
I'm gonna eat this [ __ ] and make
the hardest song ever and [ __ ] right so
I was in the studio and I ate that
[ __ ] and it was like
it was I ain't feel nothing and then
when I got in the car to like dip and
then just the colors started getting
hella vibrant and yep all a bunch of
[ __ ] I was just smiling for no reason
and [ __ ] so and then when you go to go
to sleep you close your eyes and you
start thinking like yeah way way deeper
yeah like [ __ ] yeah I was thinking deep
as [ __ ] I'm like this is crazy yeah but
now I ain't really I ain't get to that
moment I ain't get to the mode that you
got on you've been on the little god
mode you just gotta eat a whole bag
she ain't I don't want like at home you
know or like in a controlled environment
not don't do it on tour yeah do you you
tried it on tour
or you were like it was this yeah I
tried it on tour but it didn't work oh I
see I see it yes I was like I ain't
gonna [ __ ] with it no more it was kind
of nice you know what happened though
bro what I went to Amsterdam right and I
did like a whole European Festival tour
went to Amsterdam
and they will stay like you know they
open with this [ __ ] yeah so they got a
mushroom store
so you go in there they got they had
like these mushroom truffles or whatever
right so I'm like [ __ ] I'm from the
bodies [ __ ] I'm in Amsterdam
you know [ __ ] Gonna smoke nigga's
gonna pop a little mushroom whatever the
[ __ ] right so I grab it
and then I um I go to eat it
and like probably like an hour later bro
I got the sickest I've ever been like I
threw up all over h m and everything you
threw up in an h m threw up in h m how
did this not end up on TMZ
I don't know they just didn't recognize
you you do hey you threw up in hm in La
ddg pukes at h m it's just [ __ ] all
over academics and [ __ ] that's what I'm
saying but it was some low-key [ __ ] it
was just that's dope third floor H mmm
got the throwing up one of the employees
knew who I was so they grabbed me a
little bag to throw up in and [ __ ] wow
and then I left there did you have to
buy new clothes at h m because you puked
on your other one I ain't throw up on
myself I threw up on they [ __ ] sick Pew
control bro yeah so then uh you have to
buy the stuff you puked on no no no no
the guy who knew it was you just he
bought it for himself and it's probably
on eBay right now yeah I left ddg puke
infused plain black h m shirt 89.99 on
eBay
probably more than that [ __ ] maybe yeah
yeah
um so this album obviously I feel like
I feel like you've been working a lot
yeah recording a lot
um you know you've had a lot of success
during the pandemic got your first
plaque
um double Platinum double Platinum yeah
I didn't get the second one yet but
um moonwalking and Calabasas double
Platinum yep congratulations man
appreciate it man it's a big deal yeah
it is
um do you feel like you like this album
is like
I feel like you know you're in a
position where you kind of proved a lot
of people wrong being like your
background yeah do you feel like with
this album is like you're finally like
kind of out of that like prove it mode
and you're maybe a little bit more
comfortable yeah I'm way more
comfortable on this project it's more
like you know it's like
I just want people to press play at this
point you know what I'm saying like the
music there I got the talent I got the
sound and I feel like every time a
[ __ ] decide like a [ __ ] that's
hating on me or don't want to press play
just because you know me from a
different platform and [ __ ] right when
he press every [ __ ] that press play
that knows me from that other platform
be like oh this [ __ ] hard okay all
right then a fan you know what I'm
saying I just feel like my process of of
creating a fan is longer than the
average person
fair enough I mean you even just posted
a promo video of like you like your
brother was with you yeah yeah was that
kind of like a metaphor of like kind of
like what you feel like you go through
as an artist where it's like well let me
just get you to listen if I can just get
you to listen to that low-key look like
that's the mushroom talking yeah but
yeah that's low-key like half High
really is because it's like
yeah and then he was like a future
dropped the same day I'll listen to
Future first right I mean that's cool
I'll probably listen to Future [ __ ]
first you know what I'm saying I feel it
but you're thinking but if I can just
get you to the party yeah if I can get
you to the party You're Gonna Wanna Stay
in that [ __ ] turn up you know
what I'm saying so that's I feel like
that's where I'm going through right now
the [ __ ] that's in the party still in
it and you're in the party with the
double platinum record yeah so [ __ ]
everybody else look what they doing yeah
man I've been rocking shows jumping off
stages and [ __ ] up and
jumping off stage you've been doing the
uh the uh uh crowd surfing man I was in
I I got comfortable with this [ __ ] in
Europe when I was in Europe
like it'll be something they gave
sometimes I got like shitty time slots
right right so some of them I was
performing at like 7 P.M 6 30 8 P.M you
know what I'm saying I get good time
slots and I got [ __ ] there you
know what I'm saying but some of them I
get like weak time slots so I'd be like
how can I turn these [ __ ] up so
I get off stage and jump in the mosh pit
with them and like be running in circles
with them and [ __ ] rapping and [ __ ] like
that's that's nice not a lot of artists
are doing that I think they're afraid
like lawsuits or like you know yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of I jumped on somebody
in Toronto and I heard them but I don't
know who it was and [ __ ] but it's a
lawsuit coming yeah I hope you have a
lawyer as a manager he's over here for a
reason Dimitri will defend you yeah man
it's crazy I'm showing up to that show
knowing they might get jumped on by
their favorite rapper they reached up
for me yeah so I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna
jump was this on the Kevin Gates show
nah this is rolling loud Toronto OH
rolling out Toronto I saw it by the way
shout out to our guy Ty Hollywood who's
your DJ yeah yeah yeah yeah random yeah
yeah he was turning that [ __ ] up too
that was my first time working with him
shout out to Ty Hollywood shout out to
Ty that's he's been on the streets even
real forever so it's good to see him I
was like it's Tyler DJ for ddg what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah no he's doing this
did you suggest that Silvan
[Music]
hey kudos to tie good guy
um we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at my
bookie ladies and gentlemen
[ __ ] NFL season is approaching
it's my favorite time of the year God
damn it it's good times and the Rams
versus the bills is happening kicking
off the whole regular season and there's
no way to get ready for that regular
season like getting ready for that
winning season all right I'm talking
about putting some [ __ ] money
in your pocket you could be a veteran
better like me or you could be a first
time better and you just want to get a
little taste of the action my bookie has
got you because right now they got that
double deposit bonus if you sign up at
mybookie.ag right now go to my bookie
it's quick and easy let's say you put
250 bucks in you get 500 to gamble with
that's right it's a double deposit bonus
but you have to use the promo code
bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code bootleg
you got to register today use it and
let's get this NFL season [ __ ]
cracking I'm talking listen I don't even
know the line of the Rams Bills game
it's about a week out on some change
away depending on what the [ __ ] you're
watching this but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview yeah rolling loud Toronto
looked like it was a movie obviously
it's also like a
Toronto's like its own thing so some of
the like artists that like I saw on the
line was like oh that that's some
Toronto [ __ ] yeah do you feel like uh
now that you know you get this album out
is it like a burden lift it off your
shoulders because you've been working so
like I just feel like you've been
recording so much yeah man I get
I'm way more picky with my projects than
I am with like putting out music you
could throw a single out if it doesn't
work just move it yeah man I throw some
[ __ ] out you ain't like it cool yeah I'm
saying I'd throw somebody
like that all right yeah throw some
other [ __ ] out you know what I'm saying
versus a project I feel like that's
something I really want people to like
revisit yeah and I want [ __ ] to
listen to it like it's one big ass song
you know what I'm saying rather than
just
bunch of singles because it's not like
on the project
for you to understand and you got to
listen to it from
top to bottom right you know what I'm
saying because all the songs come
together you know what I mean so I'll be
that's how I be trying to make my [ __ ]
so I'll be way more I mean most people
don't do that most people are just like
let me just get some hits they don't
really think about the continuity or the
you know cohesiveness of a body of work
so that's dope especially people from
your like class of artists like your age
and [ __ ] so yeah yo
who were you supposed to fight that
didn't end up happening
um
you were supposed to the last fight yeah
the last fight but that was supposed to
be the social club [ __ ] who are you
supposed to fight pnb Rock oh God damn
it that's right it was pnb Rock Rest in
Peace man that's [ __ ] up super [ __ ]
up
I totally forgot that dude yeah man I'm
cool though that was that's why I
remember yeah you're like yo we're cool
as [ __ ] yeah you made a whole song
Together everything I was trying to chop
it up with him about it like man let's
just do this
I don't know I think it was just some
business [ __ ] or something some end up
going down super sad situation man
obviously you live in LA and you know
it could have been you yeah I mean it
could have been anybody you know what I
mean like that's what I'm saying right
that's why I'm like
I'm about to dip when you see that kind
of [ __ ] like are you like how like I
mean you're I feel like you're a pretty
careful guy when I see you moving around
like and you're also not very um
you don't flaunt a lot you know what I
mean yeah
um do you move does it make you move
around even more careful does it make
you even more conscious of what what
your surroundings and yeah bro I'm like
I got my defensive awareness out here is
A1 I ain't gonna lie yeah you know what
I'm saying I just beef
I'm always paranoid yeah I'm [ __ ] that
[ __ ] kind of ass but it's like yeah
because if you're always paranoid it's
like how can you like when can you be
comfortable right because like
yeah man that's just sad bro that's
just wild I think this is kind of a
unpopular opinion but I just think
artists should move around with no
jewelry or they should wear fake [ __ ]
and I'm not being serious like if you
wore a fake Rolex nobody would ever
question that you were wearing a fake
Rolex that's facts and you is very
effects like you know like uh you know
Chad Ochocinco the football player he
always would say I wear fake jewelry
because I'm putting my money into this
[ __ ] and nobody's ever going to look at
me they I have the money to get the real
[ __ ] but if I get robbed or something
happens it's fake go ahead take it right
or if you don't have any jewelry just
what are you gonna get away with an
iPhone that I'm gonna track and some
debit cards I'm gonna call and cancel
and like yeah so yeah I don't know man
it's I'm more so like I'm like a
collector though that's why I'll be
buying [ __ ] like I like collecting jury
and
I'm like into watches and [ __ ]
what is uh besides jewelry do you
collect anything else like Pokemon cards
or [ __ ] obviously nah just jewelry
yeah I like collecting jury
and just like reselling and [ __ ] I'm
damn near like a low-key of Jeweler down
there
were you able to take advantage of the
watch Market spiking the way it spiked
during the pandemic and make some money
no because I didn't sell okay I held my
[ __ ] but I ended up buying I bought some
[ __ ] recently and I got up I'm like up
50 off already yeah cause for people who
don't know like any precious items
basketball cards watches things that are
like one of ones like hard carryable
things like or they [ __ ] watches went
nuts during the pandemic yeah crazy
three if you buy 350 400 it's crazy
stupid prices but I didn't sell hmm But
you know it's because I like my [ __ ]
that I'll be buying so that's fair yeah
I'll be rocking it sometimes what's your
favorite song on the album
my favorite song I would say is
[Music]
um
my favorite song I would say probably
nine lives
it's called that's the one with Polo G
that's the intro right um
I like that one a lot I feel like that's
just one of them songs it's just like
all the lyrics Just resonate right you
know because I'm not capping like I
really I'm saying a song You Ever Had to
boil some water to wash your back like I
really had to go through that [ __ ] like
a big ass turkey baster right just full
of an old water because I'm like around
like 13 14 bro we had no no hot water
right so I grabbed a [ __ ] turkey
baster and we'll put the [ __ ] water
in the [ __ ] and then go pour boil it on
the stove right and then go pour it in
the tub and take a bath because the
[ __ ] water was cold and I live in
Michigan so you know it's cold outside
real cold yes I'm like
I really went through that [ __ ] and
sometimes you'll go and [ __ ] around and
pour the water in the tub and you forget
to plug that [ __ ] and they go so
telling you to lose your water bro [ __ ]
so it's like I really I really went
through that [ __ ] so I feel like a lot
of people um
um well people that don't know me right
they're like way back they don't know
what I went through they don't know how
I grew up and [ __ ] they just see the
the Glam and [ __ ] appreciate y'all
watching but listen our partners at Blue
chew they got you handled fellas and Etc
whatever you are thank God if you got a
dick Bluetooth is for you because they
will make sure your dick performs at all
time levels I mean like LeBron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
I mean your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a Bluetooth and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk I swear to God stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like a stole something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discrete
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
think me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview I mean you're
obviously pretty tapped into with the
Michigan hip-hop scene you got baby face
array on the album but Detroit Flint
everybody's going crazy right now yeah
man it's good to see because people have
been sleeping on that sound for a minute
it's going crazy like [ __ ] oh the
Freshman covers baby Tron and Babyface
Ray yeah both from Detroit so yeah man
yeah I feel like people don't put you in
that group of artists but you're from
there yeah they don't put me in that
because I've been in La so long and I
feel like I popped out in La so I feel
like I don't know right people's fair to
me like some people be calling me La
[ __ ] sometimes
I'll be like I ain't from here I feel
like
I feel like for the most part everyone
eventually ends up living in La if
you're like if you get some sort of
traction for the most part obviously I
feel like everyone has gotten at least a
six month lease out here at some point
in time yeah to chase this [ __ ] I mean
you gotta come here yeah for this [ __ ]
would you ever move
yeah I'm thinking about moving like soon
though I'm trying to I want to [ __ ] with
Atlanta Atlanta I feel like Atlanta is
like
I feel like if I lived in Atlanta
I'd be even more further in the music
it's a great City man great food
Lower State Tax
um better strip clubs yeah they just
they out there working together
they all working together I feel like in
LA everyone's kind of everyone's kind of
on their solo Mission you know yeah
everybody here
doing it and I feel like two kind of the
reasons you came to La early on were
probably for like YouTube reasons yeah
that's why that [ __ ] is like kind of
what you've kind of broken away from
that like obviously you still you know
do stuff but like it's it's like all
right well you're more of an artist now
yeah so it's like Atlanta
for the artist [ __ ] I feel like La is
for like
music I mean not music but like movie
production right you know that type of
[ __ ] talk shows you know
Productions and [ __ ] 100
um shout out to your lady you're in a
nice uh a nice romance
she uh is the new Little Mermaid yeah
which is incredible
I can't wait to see it
um first of all how dope is that just
like
that [ __ ] is historical yeah it's
amazing you know this is beautiful to
see she's been talking about that for a
minute so
I'm just really excited for yeah is she
letting any of this [ __ ] hey get to
her
nah nah
nah he's laughing it off it's kind of
crazy maybe they'd be going a little too
hard but I feel like the people is more
attacking
the character rather than her personally
you know what I'm saying Eve I feel like
it's like caught in a crossfire because
she's playing the character right but I
don't think [ __ ] is like
because any like you it's impossible to
be impossible to be mean to Hadley you
know what I'm saying she seems like the
sweetest girl she's too sweet and she
really liked that in person so it's like
it's if people actually took the time to
realize who's actually playing a Little
Mermaid instead of just going off that
she's black I think it'll they'll be
like every once in a while we get
reminded like how terribly racist
America still is yeah I didn't know if
people was just racist I didn't know I
didn't know this neither did I dude I
thought this [ __ ] was gone already I
thought that [ __ ] was gone I thought
Martin Luther King canceled that [ __ ]
out it's crazy this [ __ ] is crazy I was
like what the [ __ ] is these [ __ ]
talking about oh my God it's bad man
well at the end of the day also it's
like it's the [ __ ] is tapping
in they still gonna watch that [ __ ] oh
it's like yeah it's like thanks for the
promotion that's what I'm saying there's
no way that movie comes out is it number
one in the box office I'm saying it's
going number one regardless and every
single black person in the world is
going to watch that [ __ ] for sure for
100 every little girl gonna have the bad
[ __ ] movie ticket for that
[ __ ] it's gonna be babies in that
[ __ ] everybody from [ __ ]
zero years old to
75. they all watching that [ __ ] I think
it's been dope to see like the reactions
of like some of the little girls
watching and being like oh she looks
like me like that shit's crazy like
it's like some real inspirational [ __ ]
really changing the world man how did
you guys meet up like how did you like
end up you know hanging out slitting her
DM you know check you out
W Reese man gotta do what was the first
DM now like what was like was it like
eyeballs was it nah she had she had
posted a um
what song was it
many Man by 50 Cent
she posted a picture and put miniman
like one of my fans had told me she was
following me and I didn't know who she
was to be honest like because you know
I'm not tapped into that world that she
was in you know what I mean I'm I'm I
know about 50 Cent you know you know
what I'm saying all this [ __ ] that's
what I grew up listening to so you're
recording a joint album with blue face
let's be yeah that's what I'm saying so
I I wasn't in that world and then
somebody was like she's following your
phone man I'm like who's this so when I
tap in I do a bunch of little research
all right let me see so then she posted
like a picture of um
um herself playing many men in the
background and I was like oh that's a
nice song choice
now we're here you hit her with a nice
song Choice nice song choice and now
we're here that's great man nice song
Choice man and you're a great [ __ ]
guy sounds like both of you guys are
like super super just like chill
individuals you know
salute to you what is up with the blue
face collab album because you guys I
don't know man you guys played me some
[ __ ] I just wanna there's a song where
you guys are dissing each other yeah and
you ate them up yeah for sure you gotta
say um
you gotta say no more after that you oh
you ate them up
but nah nah I don't know what's going on
with this [ __ ]
I don't know because you guys have a
bunch of Records yeah man that shit's
supposed to come out and you guys have
great chemistry together yeah that's my
dog yeah
but I think the last time I saw you guys
you guys were recording and he had Sean
rock with him do you see their
relationship and be like okay I know now
knowing what not to do yeah but I also
you know I see I know where they're
coming from they they really love each
other you see them off of the camera off
of the IG yeah genuine love yeah it's
genuine love it's just like you know
they you know they just two fires
together but it's like it all comes from
it all comes from the heart it all comes
from a place of Love yeah so it's like
you can't get into it can't get in the
way and no [ __ ] like that
yeah I think if you guys put that on me
you guys had some dope records you play
me yeah man two people two labels is
probably you know you gotta get all that
[ __ ] figured out yeah it's too much a
lot of business behind this how many
videos on the new album already in a can
oh right now
four four because you already got the
rollout together the album is out yeah
but I'm about to I'm about to just get
to going crazy spamming spamming cleared
your IG up you took everything up took
it off through the tracklist up yeah I
took it off for um you got a video for
the polo G Chopper record yep nle try to
get you to do this penis retention calm
retention thing to be doing you know all
that holistic not ejaculating thing he
does he says it like gives him more
energy
you know it's semen retention I said
penis retention he's probably practicing
that too
pain is no he'd be doing the semen
retention where he doesn't climax
because it's like I guess it's like good
for you or something I don't know I
heard of that because that's the real
thing is it yeah I don't know he'd be in
here with his [ __ ] his CMOS
that's you know this I take CMOS I take
the pills yeah he he talking some [ __ ]
with the sea marks we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview yo
when when pnb dropped out of the fight I
had heard you and Ray J were gonna fight
yeah that almost happened right you
never got announced they never got
announced and [ __ ] but that was like a
thing that was about to happen right
like he was here that would have been
that would have been that would have
been funny that would have been crazy
yeah are you like done with the fighting
thing or can you I think I'm done bro I
ain't gonna lie yeah because it's just
like
it's just not like I feel like the
[ __ ] that's doing it actually really
want a box like they really want to
become and you're professional boxers
and I that's not where I'm trying to go
you know what I'm saying also you
probably have a lot more to lose of like
you get knocked out hell yeah way more
to lose if I was a loser fight I'm done
I already put my career on the line once
and you know what I'm saying and that's
and I won so you know it turned me up
and [ __ ] so you know I'm the bad guy I
was thinking about it but it's just like
it gotta be
you gotta make dummy sense it has to be
the money has to make sense and it has
to be something that you're like I
there's no way I don't win this fight
yeah nah I mean I I want to fight
somebody that's like gonna give me a
challenge well this is what should
happen you and blueface drop the joint
album album release party is a
Pay-Per-View fight you guys fight each
other that would be lit see that makes
sense that makes sense that makes sense
you guys both come out on top because
you're out there so it's like he could
beat me up I could beat him up he
probably has a little reach you probably
got the technique though good you know
that that'll make that is be something
that makes Krishan Rock she's like the
referee
so it's your Fox because she's gonna you
know yeah
she might toy on you too yeah
well like the album is out uh if you're
watching this it's out go run that thing
up uh is the video are we the video
already out
yep it's out now
when is the interview dropping we'll
probably drop it Monday or Tuesday next
week yep it's dry it's out now and since
Monday or Tuesday
might be a little Deluxe or something or
you're gonna run the deluxe back huh go
get the album and the deluxe no don't be
out we'll wait until so look we'll just
hold on to is the deluxe coming out
Monday
so one
good Dimitri so you're going to do a
deluxe if you're watching this it's just
because okay so if you're watching this
it was recorded before the album came
out but go listen to the [ __ ] Deluxe
it might be out too yeah yeah hopefully
hopefully but it's gonna be out how many
extra songs
it's on like four exercises
yeah I ain't want to overdo it and put
no 30 40 songs on that [ __ ] yeah uh go
run it up man hey I also I tell this to
people all the time I feel like you are
um
you're like most improved rapper I feel
like it man I feel like when I when when
you first came out and you came to the
radio station I would listen to your
[ __ ] and I'd be like yeah it's cool for
a YouTuber yeah but now like I'm like yo
you're on your [ __ ] bro like you've
really improved like not even like just
like you're better than like most of
these kids that are in your [ __ ] you
know in in your world appreciate that
man so salute man the records are dope
I'm glad you got your [ __ ] double
Platinum yes sir I'm going for the
second one second one nine lives Nine
Lives gotta hit and you have another
plaque too right yeah I wouldn't go
independently this before I was gonna
say it was like one of your earlier
records
singing singing wow what can I do next
time do a rock album [ __ ] it don't do
that you're right don't do that nobody
wanted that [ __ ] okay all right
respectfully
there it is ddg Boom